[Music]
there was a woman
a woman who poisoned her partner good
and stole 75 000 pounds while he was in
a hospital with chronic diarrhea that's
what it gets that's what women do bro
you won't even need to poison me for
that
that's just me after taco bell
that's what you get no that's what women
do do women are shady man they always do
they just wait till you have chronic
diarrhea
that's what i noticed so this woman in
spain allegedly killed her partner with
laxatives who killed him
that's a problem say that in the
beginning anthony i feel bad we're still
in the beginning
fourth day [ __ ] to death yeah he
dehydrated himself probably a heart
attack probably more of a dehydrating
himself so you [ __ ] it so much
you dehydrated that can happen
remember like if you get diarrhea as a
kid or whatever they're like really like
gotta pump you full of fluids because
otherwise you just treat yourself to
death yeah yeah dysentery
organ transplant is already
hospital for this chronic diary oh [ __ ]
so the hospital also [ __ ] up so this
is actually a really [ __ ] up story i
don't know why i'm smiling now okay all
he needed was some pepto-bismol every
time i got diarrhea dude take a little
pepto-bismol that [ __ ] blocks it up and
then for some reason my kaka is always
black too [ __ ] golden pink goes out
black so buy pepto-bismol so the
70-year-old man
was in a hospital in
valencia for seven months with chronic
diarrhea seven months and medicine
struggled to improve his health
according to local reports one of the
reasons investigators started suspecting
his partner was because the patient's
health would improve when he was
admitted to intensive care no where he
wasn't allowed over time
what was she doing like spiking his
[ __ ] coffee or something but it would
worsen whenever he was put back into the
normal ward yo that's kind of [ __ ] up
because someone [ __ ] up there somebody
should be checking in on that that's
like that's you like when people go to
like hospitals continuously
like over seven months that's a long
[ __ ] time nobody was like hey man you
keep getting this crazy diarrhea and
this [ __ ] happens all the time too where
people like there's stories of people
poisoning
their [ __ ] uh husband or wife or
whatever trying to cash in on that life
insurance maybe so it was his relatives
that contacted the authorities after
noticing that the 75 000 pounds of his
savings had gone missing from his
account
his unnamed 56 year old girlfriend is
said to have withdrawn more than 50 000
of it from his bank account and spent
the other 25 000 using debit and credit
cards was that his arm candy what's arm
candy where it wasn't like a love based
relationship oh yeah which is 56 but bus
stop she's probably fine
i don't know like like kind of like was
that his like wife from long long time
ago or was that his new fling yeah yeah
it seems like a new new situation
she was arrested by detectives and they
seized several receipts for medicine to
treat constipation why would you keep
the receipts oh so she was just giving
him
diuretics
wow you're gonna buy it with cash bro
she couldn't throw away the receipts
as well as being held in relation to the
death of her partner she is also being
investigated on suspicion of
misappropriation fraud maybe she wanted
to write off all the when the insurance
fraud money came in she would be like yo
dude to get him dead i had to [ __ ]
you got
that's way better of a term than to kill
him hey to get him dead i have to it
seems way lighter doesn't it
who got this guy dead
it also tells you like the exact caliber
of criminal you're working with you're
just like all right you're uh an evil
genius right here evil genius man so
laxative abuse leads to the body being
deprived of the minerals and
electrolytes it needs for proper
functioning of the nerves and muscles
and it can result in serious intestinal
harm as well as damage to the kidneys
heart and liver heart attack that's why
you're supposed to drink [ __ ]
pedialyte after you diarrhea man
pepto-bismol pedialyte man solving
problems that's what they don't have
valencia valencia
dude that sucks because this guy was
like otherwise totally healthy right he
should have been fine yeah dude seven
imagine seven months bro of diarrhea
[ __ ] yourself yeah i could have done
that to my roommate back in the day on
and i wouldn't have [ __ ] known
because like we we used to always pranks
like i'm sorry
we used to do these pranks on each other
um and he would sign me up for free
samples of all these stupid [ __ ] and
then one of the samples he signed me up
for was like these cookies that make you
[ __ ] and i would just keep receiving him
in the middle now what the [ __ ] we keep
getting these diarrhea cookies and then
i found it was him so when he was like
sleepy i was like hey wake up eat this
cookie i was like trying to feed him and
he he was like oh yeah yeah i was like
just eat it eat it and then he's like
all right [ __ ] it he started eating it
and i was like i [ __ ] got you dude i
was like dude
i could have killed him yeah could have
made him [ __ ] his way to death yeah we
did that for seven months i would have
done it every day seven months yeah i i
definitely also pranked a homie back in
college with some like xlax and we just
thought it was mad funny because like
when this guy was like a leader of an
organization so it was like a major like
event weekend and then like he was
always like kind of gone because he has
to go take [ __ ]
did you do that to jason no no i didn't
do that to jason but they remember you
know the way to like kind of let him
know was to eventually just be like dude
man i don't know if it was something i
ate
you know we
what were you sneaking it in it was
x-lax chocolate oh so it comes in like
chocolate yeah but like take the
chocolate and then you either just like
mix it in with other chocolate
literally it's just like chocolate you
want some chocolate because you don't
you're not gonna [ __ ] think your
homies giving you a laxative well now i
do
i did a prank that's like the most
efficient version of that but uh this
one dancer guy he like got so drunk at a
party that we were at and he like
knocked out and fell asleep on the floor
and we wanted him to think that he shot
so we we got chocolate and our friends
stuck chocolate up his ass
while he was sleepy
holy [ __ ] he pulls his pants down and he
got he got the hershey's little squares
for s'mores
one by one just started putting him in
his that's [ __ ] dude the body heat
would melt it yeah it would just become
a pull up bro
there's so many more
things that we didn't wake up to see him
wake up so we to this day we have no
idea what he was thinking
so he put a bunch of chocolate in my
hand you never told him i think you know
these guys too i'll tell you later but
yeah yeah because
the first thing i do is check my ass and
go oh no i [ __ ] but the second thing i
do is smell it and i go
oh
oh that's chocolate no that's still ass
chocolate you have like residue you
wouldn't eat chocolate from your ass no
i wouldn't lick it
but you gotta taste it i mean i would
immediately smell it and go
that's chocolate
chocolate i'm around ryan i'm gonna
pretend to fall asleep with my butt
cheeks open a little bit oh man i'm so
tired right what if you did [ __ ]
yourself and then the chocolate was on
top of that
i didn't think about that
[ __ ] chocolate
like what if you had both and like
unbeknownst to you he like never
it felt like so relaxed so he's like she
might as well keep [ __ ] kind of like
the whole prank where if you put a hot
water in your hands yeah you start
peeing and [ __ ]
wow let's try it it's a case study
i feel like if if someone put like warm
water on my [ __ ] on my dick if i was
sleeping right if they poured it i think
i might just start peeing i think i
would too yeah did you guys ever try the
fingers in the water trick i didn't know
that well i don't know if it really
works i always just saw it in the movies
yeah it was kind of it works it does i
think it works
i'm not going to say why
but i think it works to jason no who the
[ __ ] is jason
who the [ __ ] is jake jason park oh jason
park you have to just jason parker
oh my god i peed my pants in hawaii
recently you guys ever do that though
you just volunteer this information like
yeah
this last time you were there nah this
was like during um spring 2021 a spring
of twenties that's the last time i
picked a good season to pee your pants
i uh i i slept on the balcony we were on
this [ __ ] high-rise
place and then i slept outside on the
balcony because i was like yo it's
comfortable you know
and then um warm cups of water
[Laughter]
oh this is gonna be great
and then um yeah in the morning it was
just like you know you have those dreams
where you pee right and then you go oh
no
i didn't make it to the bathroom or
whatever and you wake up you're like oh
thank god yeah i uh you know it's a
dream
i'm like wait a minute and like
involuntarily it's going right and i had
to check so i went inside and i [ __ ]
looked in and i'm like oh no it's
[ __ ] peeing outside i'll hold my dick
and i ran to the bathroom and i finished
it off wait
you just let me get this straight there
was a moment where you're like oh [ __ ]
luckily it was a dream
and then you went
ahead it's real like it was like like
pink to my [ __ ] belly and i'm like
it's real so i [ __ ] did the cut-off
thing right wait a minute it's real i
hit the [ __ ] male kegel cut right hey
it could happen you got to stop that
flow it hurt though like crazy and then
i [ __ ] did the kegel cut and then i
ran to the bathroom
i released
and i was like damn dude i haven't
pissed my pants since i was a child it
was a nostalgic feeling that's the next
otr
the last time you pissed your pants yeah
i took a quick little shower good old
days on my pants yeah reminiscent about
how you used to pee your pants
i just love the like the image of like
everyone's like up and eating breakfast
everyone was sleeping yeah no no but
like imagine if they're all at the like
dinner table or whatever like eating a
nice comfortable breakfast they just
hear from the outside like oh no
it's real
yeah if you're done with that you want
to eat
i mean you know me though in the morning
i told everybody dude
i was like i pissed myself this morning
i can't wait to tell people i feel like
next time you don't have to
you could just come out like this and go
it happened again
[Laughter]
joe
and you know what he was unapologetic
about it [ __ ] five or four or
whatever i like his style bart went into
the room and you go did you did you pee
your pants because he wouldn't get out
of bed and he goes yup
[Music]
you